bonsoir mesdames et messieurs je
m'appelle madame descends descends
laurence plus exactement on m'appelle
aussi merci merci on m'appelle aussi
coach dollars et mon thème de ce soir ce
sera comment transformer les noms en oui
bonsoir mesdames et messieurs j'entends
presque des oufs dit si vous n'avez pas
fait tout ce chemin là pour écouter la
précédente version de moi n'est ce pas
n'est ce pas vous êtes tous plus détendu
j'ai vu quelqu'un qui essayait de
m'encourager vas-y vas-y merci c'est
gentil
alors pourquoi est-ce que j'ai joué ce
rôle c'était dans le but d'introduire
mon message de ce soir transformé lennon
en oui par la qualité de notre
communication en quelques secondes
je viens de vous prouver que présentait
la meilleure version de soi et le bon
message et le chemin direct vers la
réceptivité de votre public qu'il
s'agisse d'une personne ou de 1000
personnes
je peux être une personne exceptionnelle
vous pouvez être une personne
extraordinaire mais l'acceptation ou le
rejet de votre interlocuteur va dépendre
de notre qualité de votre capacité à
communiquer efficacement alors en quinze
minutes je crois
ce soir je vais essayer de vous montrer
comment est-ce que notre communication
peut être utilisé comme un outil
puissant et je souligne trois fois le
mot puissant pour définir qui nous
sommes d'où vient où on va et transformé
lennon en oui qu'est ce que j'appelle un
oui
alors quand on m'a appelé comme a dit
laurence on souhaiterait inviter
intervenir à la première édition de tedx
grand bassam j'ai tout de suite dit oui
je me suis dit coach de l'as c'est la
meilleure manière de commencer ton année
2010 est et pourquoi parce que
participer partager mes idées et ma
vision au cours d'un ted x faisait
partie de la longue liste des choses que
j'avais prévu à faire dans ma vie
donc ce soir en rentrant chez moi
grâce à vous il y aura une case en plus
de cocher textes réalisés
[Applaudissements]
ma liste elle est longue elle et l'ont
pourquoi pas ce que j'attends beaucoup
de la vie je suis une grande rêveuse
comme il a dit au moment de
l'introduction mes rêves ne maintienne
éveillé je ne parle pas de ses rêves que
l'on fait le soin la nuit les yeux
fermés mes rêves me maintiennent en
action
me maintiennent créative nous avons tous
des rêves des projets et des aspirations
vous avez des rêves des projets et des
aspirations
quels sont vos rêves en ce début d'année
on a de nouvelles résolutions n'a de
nouvelles aspirations
alors je vais faire un petit sondage
rapide alors je ne peux m'empêcher de
faire participer
mon public je vais vous demander de
faire quelque chose rapidement alors ce
sera d'applaudir d'applaudir en fonction
de ce que je vais dire je vais listes et
des aspirations que vous avez
probablement et si il s'agit d'une
aspiration qui vous qui vous concerne
vous applaudissez si c'est quelque chose
qui est très important pour vous
applaudissez encore plus fort et si
c'est quelque chose qui ne vous concerne
pas vous n'applaudissez pas instructions
simples n'est ce pas alors fait un petit
exercice santé non j'ai vite et
positivité prospérité médiocrité
adversité il ya des personnes qui veut
de l'adversité ok c'est bon à savoir
négativité silence total comme on dit en
côte d'ivoire nous attendons tous et
nous espérons tous recevoir ce qu'on
appelle les bontés nous attendons tous
une réponse positive de la vie c'est ce
que j'appelle des oui alors quelle est
la meilleure manière pour obtenir les
choses auxquelles on aspire
il faut déjà commencer par les demandes
et me direz c'est évident coach mais mon
point ici est de dire que très souvent
les demandes que nous faisons vaut faire
face et rencontrer des non monsieur ted
votre candidature n'a pas été retenue
madame x votre contrat ne sera pas
renouvelé monsieur y
votre produit ne m'intéresse pas
mademoiselle x
je préfère mettre fin à cette relation
comment mettre fin à cette succession à
cette collection de nom comment ne plus
faire face à toutes ces situations
auxquels on a affaire et on a
l'impression que notre mode est sur le
point de s'écrouler
est ce qu'il existe une formule magique
je ne le sais pas mais ce que je sais
c'est qu'il existe des techniques et des
méthodes pour réduire la distance entre
nous et nos aspirations promotion emploi
mariage chiffre d'affaires qui explose
monsieur ted
vous nous avez fait une impression mais
extraordinaire je vais vous faire une
offre d'emploi
madame x vous êtes promu au poste de
directrice marketing du groupe
c'est là que vous devez applaudir là
monsieur y
votre produit m'interessent comment je
fais pour souscrire mademoiselle x
je veux vous épousez alors transformé
lennon ans oui c'est la question
les oui sont généralement la conséquence
d'une série d'actions une série
d'actions ou généralement on a conquis
on a prouvé on a mérité on a séduit la
réelle question c'est donc comment
convaincre
comment prouver comment vendre comment
séduire
alors ce soir je vais vous donner de
petites techniques
la règle des 5 c est la méthode de la
connexion lorsque l'on souhaite
on se développer un langage le langage
de la persuasion
il est important de s'assurer que le
message les mots qu'on utilise servent
bel et bien notre objectif
le premier c'est la clarté est ce que le
message est compréhensif de tous le
deuxième c'est il faut que le message
soit complet pas de train pas de pas de
faux fuyant un message transparent
message au net sans confusion
le troisième c'est la courtoisie il est
inutile d'un texte est méprisé attaquer
quatrième c'est la cohérence
il est important que ce message servent
donc votre objectif est le dernier c'est
la concision un message qu'on s'y avec
des mots
percutant alors quand il s'agit de
parler maintenant du principe de la
connexion alors au niveau du principe de
la connexion c'est très simple quand
vous parlez dans le message il est
important de se rapprocher de son
interlocuteur il ne s'agit pas de
excusez moi je sais en dur ou de partir
vers la personne mais bien évidemment de
se rapprocher à je sens la clim ici est
ce que j'ai le droit de s'en tirer alors
il ne s'agit pas de se rapprocher
physiquement mais il s'agit de parler
certes aux oreilles mais de chercher la
voie vers le coeur de votre
interlocuteur afin qu'il intègre et
qu'ils adhèrent à l'information
j'enseigne les techniques de
communication de vente de négociation
dans les universités je développe des
programmes de formation pour les
entreprises
je donne des conférences j'organise des
plateformes de motivation et
d'inspiration meet and greet africa par
exemple l'année dernière j'ai reçu le
prix du jeune entrepreneur innovant du
patronat ivoirien
[Applaudissements]
merci mais mon histoire ne commence pas
là il y a cinq ans j'ai développé une
pneumopathie aggravé d'une pleurésie en
france est simple j'avais une infection
pulmonaire très avancés avec de l'eau
dans le poumon jeu souffrait
terriblement parce que l'eau dans le
poumon affecté ma colonne vertébrale je
ne pouvais pas marcher
m'asseoir était atroce je suis resté
sans deux jours dans un environnement
médicalisé à deux doigts de la ceni mais
journée ressembler à quoi perfusion
prélèvements sanguins injection
perfusion prélèvements sanguins
injection aidez-moi perfusion
prélèvements sanguins injection au pot
ou ne retrouvait plus mes veines on ne
trouvait plus de 20 mais vaine n'était
plus utilisable mais ce n'était pas le
plus douloureux
le plus douloureux c'était que j'ai
passés sans deux jours loin de mes deux
enfants mes deux garçons à cette époque
mon aîné pierre loïc avait juste deux
ans et le petit dernier qu'un drik sept
mois à cette époque j'avais à peine 200
mille francs sur mon compte en banque
ce ne sont pas des histoires à cette
époque je vivais chez ma mère parce que
j'étais une mère célibataire
à cette époque j'étais sans emploi
et pourtant diplômé d'une entre d'une
université américaine
je peux vous dire
que mon monde était littéralement en
train de s'écrouler
mais une chose qui est sûre une chose
que je sais faire une chose pour
laquelle je peux me vanter aujourd'hui
d'avoir de l'expérience c'est bel et
bien de transformer les noms de la vie
en oui
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'est ce que je viens de faire
je viens de vous montrer comment on
utilise la règle des 5 c est de parler
au coeur
dans la salle beaucoup d'entre vous
m'ont presque imaginer dans cet hôpital
ont ressenti ma précarité ont eu de la
compassion pour moi santé la douleur de
mes veines il existe des techniques pour
améliorer votre capacité à convaincre et
à persuader un recruteur un prospect un
client un investisseur un prétendant ces
techniques là il y en a pas mal
différente mais je ne suis pas là
aujourd'hui pour vous parler de
formation malheureusement je suis là
pour vous parler immortel le langage
immortel copie de tous les speakers de
ce soir si on me demandait coach nola
qu'est-ce que tu souhaiterais qu'on
retienne de toi je dirai tout de suite
que je souhaiterais qu'une personne dise
on nous a appris à lire et à écrire mes
coaches ne la crée une entreprise
innovante qui m'a appris à parler et
convaincre une entreprise humaine qui
m'a appris à déplacer les montagnes de
la vie et atteindre mes objectifs
une entreprise inspirante qui m'a
accompagné à réaliser mes rêves
aujourd'hui j'ose rêver grand
sereinement
si on me demande coach lola comment
restera dessus immortel rats ma réponse
est très simple
je dirais que coach le là tous les
matins s'élever à prier à travailler
avec détermination pour aider des
individus à écrire des histoires
différentes des histoires
extraordinaires des histoires immortel
des histoires avec des personnages
épanouie des histoires avec moins de
pleurs et plus deux rives des histoires
avec moins de défaites et plus de
victoires des histoires avec moins de
nom et +2 si je réussis à faire tout
cela alors je pourrais dire que coach
n'a est immortel je suis coach de la
merci
[Applaudissements]